vous êtes con à la gaffe qui variait
dans un instant et la garde quand il
arrivait dans l'émission était comment
mais est ce que vous avez peut-être un
signe distinctif voilà ce qu'on pouvait
faire à nos téléspectateurs ayant noté
le truc tu préfères voilà vous quand
vous arrivez dans une émission jonathan
que soyez comme la gaffe qui est un truc
il s'adonne à l'egypte à gmac a steady
casas à cagnes à les hashtags tristesse
[Applaudissements]
as tu as créé cette année ces balades
vous l'a fait dans les mines à imola
bonnes notes sont mortes tombent à
déménager caricature
[Applaudissements]
ah non non non attendez ya rien de plus
angoissant jalempo sa ducati dati mais
y'a des mecs qui peut pas laisser
pratiquer
[Applaudissements]
n'empêche ça car ça me déprime savez
comment c'est déprimant avec la veste en
1982 la semaine dernière cité mode c'est
fini ça va très vite c'est moi vous me
saoule et là on dirait que vous parler
mais je vous entends pas en fait oui je
disais c'est indémodable à l'essai par
ailleurs c'est pour ça que ça c'est bien
marché elle a été elle a été dans fort
boyard c'est la seule balle qui va fort
boyard qui on trouve que les clés de
chez elle
[Applaudissements]
mais jean michel maire allez-y j'imagine
qu'une brique ou si des gens qu'on
attend du bdp amer ni boire et la
résidence à sotchi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour la table
j'adore les inventer un truc c'est de
l'année prochaine qu'on ne va plus à
bordeaux il a gagné 1 à l'écart
christine kelly ex csa on a lu deux où
ça alors j'ai hâte de savoir où elle va
faire attention tant du tout nouveau
passants mais la magie de jean mimi web
alors vous avez vu dans la bouteille de
lea michele
[Applaudissements]
alors ouais ben ali jalloul un pourboire
dans la bouteille
après jean-michel je suis dans
l'incapacité physique de est-ce que
voilà si je vous laisse présenter les
mêmes derrière ma mère je vois pas donc
je suis est-ce que vous soyez capable
maintenant parce que c'est un truc de
ouf
est ce que vous seriez capable d'en
avoir derrière jean michel bien qu est
ce que je gagne bah oui vous les prêts
voulait faire voulez quoi bah quelque
chose un cadeau week end une gâterie
[Applaudissements]
sa reprise
tu sors ou la lâcher payet mais c'est
pas le même rang duquel s'est pas rendue
que quand vous des pistes or est par
contre j'aurai sa pêche j'ai bu dans sa
bouteille avec christine kelly s'est
toujours là c'est pas mal c'est chic
chic chic sur la table mais on dirait
les jo de colle ou non des intérêts qui
déprime nous on a envoyé monsieur prime
un peu mais c'est pas grave j'ai préparé
un truc je tends navarin a donc vous
avez tout le temps de cinq personnes
pour préparer un truc c'est ça moi je
l'est déjà je les tiens si vous voulez
d'accord mais vous nous direz oui merci
oui est-ce que je peux crier non
d'habitude franchement non on n'est plus
dans ce délire non mais laissez loin
qu'on a quand même non non encore
d'accord je sens que je vais avoir de
blanc vit de manière décalée canal
décalé canal
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est bon je vous rappelle que chacun
puisse qu'on va avoir la garde dans un
instant qu'à un gimmick voilà qui est
devenue culte cbb way et chacun trouve
un gimmick pour démarrer sa démission
pour l'instant le meilleur c'est jean
michel mercier a annoncé hier coincé pas
de laisser les siens en plus totale est
persuadé qu'on lui demande son avis sur
tout j'adore demandez moi non mais c'est
bon vous alors vous à ça va être intense
y aura alors la retour en arrière
ce soir c'est à lakota
c'était quoi c'est pas malin et l'eau
qui dit elle a rien compris padam padam
on arrive là tu arrêtes tu n'apportes
quoi elle en fait c'est même pas ce
qu'elle fait dans cette voie oui c'est
d'abord à lakota ce sens et panna cotta
c'est vous dire est retombé par la
comptable n'allait pas s'ils allaient ou
non mais c'est sympa d'avoir participé
isabelle vous savez que vous êtes je
voulais vous rendre hommage c'est une
trouvaille à vous ça ouais ça y est un
as compris à la vidéo
moi c'est ça nommage au pays basque vous
allez voir moi je me sens pas du tout je
suis sûr que ça va être le plus triste
de foot sinon si c'est bien possible et
sebha où je me suis fait sortir mon
attention
je compte sur vous ouais bon bon bon bon
bon bon bon bon ben voila merci d'un
public soit agi de manière choix de loi
qui chérit
je dois de shalit oui mais qui souffre
et on a quand même un ouf
ils se promènent la vie ça commence bien
par autre bon santé numéro en plus pour
brailler soir pour le public pour
l'instant c'est moi le numéro t pour une
moins bonne des numéros pour moi et pour
la conseillère principale voyez ils ont
réagi aux les tagueurs récollets ainsi
alors oui alors où les combats vous vous
êtes le sniper aujourd'hui aux 81 oui au
revoir c'est quoi alors la dédicace à
vrai dire je suis content de rester huit
ans pour voir ça aux armes citoyens
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour desserrer b voulait qu'on dise
voilà c'est ça on n'arrive pas de
famille cetera mais sinon non aux armes
aux armes c'est géraldine maillet c'est
géraldine maillet on va tous les coups
nick wey à l'ong hemingway
bon allez besoin d'accords dans le coup
on va demander à nos styles pas alors
vous suivez un à l'aviation avec eni des
idées deux faits sur le prime oui mais
en optimisation du travail
pas mal c'est efficace ces slogans cdu
précise improvisation alors finalement
mais t'es pas l'impression normalement
c'est vous la djette de l'émission c'est
vous n'en avoir rapport auquel rappant
vraiment c'est vous qui devez mettre
l'ambiance
donc là c'est un truc dans leur phase
voulait faire une entrée une entrée
comme ça voilà arrivés là et vous faites
votre truc à goudé de bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans touche pas à mon poste
non plus au rugby mik oui mais c'est une
dédicace à un chroniqueur
ah je vois ce que je vous dis là c'est
pas là ce soir
ah bon je sais ce que c'est alors allez
y ça dans ce jeu c'est parti c'est
vraiment pour un chroniqueur web évaluer
non mais c'est quoi cette entrée de
merde ici ça non c'est quoi ce n'était
pas les jo lui qui pour qu'elle lui
fasse des bas côtés si c'est le moine
voilà